[Música]
Sean bienvenidos a un episodio más de
historia en France 24 Mi nombre es
Álvaro cordero Este 29 de mayo cumplen
75 años las fuerzas para el
mantenimiento de la paz de Naciones
Unidas también conocidas como Los cascos
azules Este cuerpo militar fue creado en
el contexto de la guerra fría con el
objetivo de intervenir en conflictos
armados de todo el mundo para mantener
la paz y proteger a la población civil
Aunque durante las últimas décadas ha
vivido numerosas polémicas debido a su
incapacidad e ineficiencia para
intervenir en algunos conflictos y a
varios escándalos por abusos sexuales a
mujeres cometidos por sus tropas
esta agencia de Naciones Unidas posee
más de 90.000 tropas repartidas en 12
misiones entre varios continentes la
mayoría de estos países en conflictos se
encuentran situados en África como
podemos ver en este mapa como pueden ser
Mali Sudán o la democrática del Congo
aunque también hay misiones en Europa en
kosovo y en chipre en varios territorios
de medio oriente y en Asia lo tenemos en
India y Pakistán su primera misión
comenzó en el año
1948 durante la Primera Guerra a la
virrey Poco después de que Israel se
convirtiera en un estado independiente
para ese momento un contingente de
tropas internacionales fue destinado a
esa zona para mediar y garantizar La
tregua tras el conflicto una misión que
se prolonga hasta el día de hoy
pero el concepto pacifista y
multinacional con el que surgió esta
agencia de la ONU quedó
eclipsado por el contexto de la Guerra
Fría esto es debido a que este
contingente militar puede actuar
solamente bajo mandato del Consejo de
Seguridad de Naciones Unidas pero en
este organismo Estados Unidos la unión
soviética Francia Reino Unido y China
tenían derecho a Beto por lo que si una
de estas naciones no estaba de acuerdo
la misión no se establecía a pesar de
ello las fuerzas de paz de la ONU
tuvieron relativo éxito en la mediación
de algunos conflictos como el que hubo
entre India y Pakistán en el año 1949
Estableciendo una misión que ha
intentado mantener la paz desde aquel
entonces también es destacable su
participación en chipre desde el año
1964 al evitar una guerra entre
chipriotas turcos y chipriotas griegos y
mantener una relativa estabilidad en la
zona desmilitarizada que divide a esta
Isla estas misiones hicieron que la
credibilidad de Los cascos azules fuera
alta y que se redoblarán sus
expectativas especialmente después de la
guerra fría y del relajamiento de las
tensiones internacionales
es así como las misiones de Los cascos
azules en todo el mundo se multiplicaron
Aunque la realidad vislumbró que su
eficacia era limitada en la década de
los 90 se produjeron algunos de los
mayores fracasos de esta agencia de
Naciones Unidas como su pasividad Y
dejadez ante el conflicto de Ruanda de
1994 que terminó en un genocidio a más
de 800.000 personas de etnia tutsi o la
incapacidad de actuar frente a las
matanza de esbrenique en 1995 cuando
cascos azules presenciaron sin tener la
orden de actuar el asesinato de más de
8.000 bosniacos a manos de tropas servo
bosnias las causas son claras Los cascos
azules no están preparados para los
conflictos modernos ya que solo acaparan
el 0,5% del gasto mundial y como vemos
las grandes potencias apenas contribuyen
en número de soldados a estos cascos
azules de hecho los países más
representativos son Etiopía nepal y
Ruanda naciones que tienen un ejército
que no está lo suficientemente preparado
para estos grandes conflictos en muchas
ocasiones y que muchas veces llevan allí
a sus soldados simplemente para mejorar
y entrenar a estas personas y obtener
beneficios económicos además a los
problemas operativos se sumaron en los
últimos 20 años los escándalos sexuales
reportados casos que están lejos de ser
puntuales y que han llevado a decenas de
denuncias de mujeres en países como
República centroafricana Guinea
República democrática del Congo o Haití
llegando a reportarse casos de mujeres
que eran abusadas a cambio de medicinas
o comida este es uno de esos muchos
testimonios que hay
estaba en Puerto Príncipe y caminaba
junto a la base de la ONU cuando un
soldado de Naciones Unidas me llamó le
dije que no quería nada pero me cogió de
la mano y me llevó a la base me cogió y
se subió encima de mí para violarme al
cabo de un rato me soltó y corrí a casa
su fracaso en Haití es especialmente
sonado ya que además de no poder poner
freno a la violencia y de cometer abusos
contribuyeron a la contaminación del
agua con cólera
factores que favorecieron su salida de
la isla y que aumentaron el descrédito
de Los cascos Azules y su forma de
actuación en estos 75 años Los cascos
azules han tenido luces y sombras en las
71 misiones realizadas a cabo es
indudable que su presencia ha
contribuido a mantener La Paz o a
reducir el conflicto en algunos casos
pero también que sus polémicas y falta
de capacidad han minado su credibilidad
como un agente capaz de realizar las
funciones para las que fue creado
con esto concluimos si quieren conocer
más historias sigan conectados a France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]